pop
[Applaudissements]
faut pas pleurer comme ça demain ou dans
un mois
tu dépenses europe
pourquoi pleurer comme ça
aujourd'hui c'est pour toi que nous
sommes
ne dit rien si tu veux mais sèche un peu
tes yeux et ne soit pas surtout
que nous autres
on s'en fout c'est
sa soeur
à
simple
domaine
dans un coin
faut pas pleurer comme ça
leur époque et pourquoi pour quelques
souvenirs
pour quelques mots d'amour jeter dans
une cour et qui s'en vont
ouvrir le dit rien si tu veux mais c'est
chape des yeux et ne crois pas surtout
que tu es l'homme on s'en fout c'est
[Musique]
sa seule
est ce un peu lasse un peu dormi et
apple
dans un coin
m
faut pas pleurer comme ça
demain ce sera toi
ça va nous parler
quand tu n'y as pas voir tu pourra nous
faire croire que tout s'oublier et pour
l'instant les doigts pour parler on est
là et ne crois pas surtout que nous on
s'en fout
seul
lore
ça fait ça sert à rien
laisse un peu
dormir ta peine
dans un coin
[Musique]